sleep deprivation makes us irritable
yeah there's it's clear so that in the
early part of the night we get
a higher percentage of those old trading
cycles are
occupied by slow wave sleep sometimes
just called non-rem sleep
and those early night sleep bouts
are great for muscular repair and for
certain forms of learning
but rem sleep the rapid eye movement
sleep which it starts to accumulate and
occupy more of those
90-minute ultradian cycles toward the
late part of a sleep bout so toward
typically toward morning but toward
after you've been asleep a while
that's when you do the emotional
processing that's when
we recover the ability to feel refreshed
and not irritated by things and
if you deprive people of rem sleep they
become selectively
uh bad at uncoupling the emotion from
things that happened in the previous
days so the little things start to seem
like big things
i always know i'm rem sleep deprived
when um
i'm irritable and when um i look at like
the word the and it doesn't look like
it's spelled right and i'm kind of
pissed off about it
something's off and we actually are
becoming slightly
um psychotic when we're rem sleep
deprived
you're not going to get a lot of rem
sleep in this thing except as you
fatigue more if you do fall asleep
you're going to drop more and more into
rem so that
those 90-minute cycles you won't have to
go through stage 1 stage 2 stage three
and then rem
you're just gonna drop right into rem so
you can count on your system to
compensate for you
but i think that just the knowledge that
you tend to get irritable as the time
goes on just that third personing of
yourself and that awareness the observer
that can be very beneficial because
there may be bouts during this event
when you just
should probably say nothing and maybe
you just um
i don't know smile and record or not
smile or do
do whatever it is because you're going
to be conserving energy if it feels like
a grind that's epinephrine being
released
that's epinephrine that you could devote
to the physical effort
but humor is an amazing anecdote for
this because
it resets that it's that dopamine
release
that gives us that fresh perspective and
it's a it's a real chemical thing
it's not a it's not a hack it's not a
it's not a trick it's not a
visualization
it's biology in action
you